- [Voiceover] Which circles
are divided into fourths?
Select all that apply.
Well to be divided into fourths,
that means we have to be divided
into four equal sections.
Cause a fourth is gonna be one
of the four equal sections.
So all of these are
divided into four sections
but not all of them are divided
into four equal sections.
For example this one is
divided into four sections
but this section right over here
is bigger than this
section right over here.
and its bigger than
this section over here.
So this isn't four equal sections.
But these top three, it looks
like four equal sections.
It looks like each of these
four sections are equal.
Each of these four sections are equal,
each of these four sections are equal.
So all of these up here
are divided into fourths
and this one isn't so I
wont click on that one.
Let's keep going, this is fun.
Which squares are divided into fourths?
Select all that apply.
Well same idea.
We have to be divided
into four equal sections.
So all of these are
divided into four sections.
One, two, three, four,
one, two, three, four.
But not all of them are divided
into four equal sections.
For example, this one right
over here, this section,
this little triangle is much
smaller than this section.
So these aren't equal sections.
But for the other three they
are four equal sections.
Each of these triangles that
this squares divided into,
these are all equal.
They all have the same area.
So that's four equal sections.
Each of these smaller squares,
they all have the same area.
So that's four equal sections.
And then each of these four rectangles
are all the same size.
They all have the same area.
So that's for equal sections.
Let's keep going.
I'm having a lot of fun.
Alright, which circles
are divided into thirds?
Well if your to divide to thirds,
you have to be dividing
into three equal sections.
So this one is divided
into four equal sections.
So this is divided into fourths.
So it's not thirds.
This is divided into three
sections but they're not equal.
This section right over here
is smaller than this
section right over here.
This one is divided into three sections
and they're all equal.
This section has the same
area as this section,
has the same area as that section.
So I'll check that one.
This one is three sections
but they're not equal just like this one.
This section is much
smaller than this section.
So this is the only one that
is really divided into thirds.
Which circles are divided into thirds?
Same idea.
This is divided into fourths.
These are aren't equal sections.
Not equal sections.
This one is divided into thirds.
Let's do one more.
Which rectangles are divided into fourths?
Remember fourths, it needs
to be four equal sections.
This looks like four equal sections.
This is two equal sections.
This is divided into halves not fourths.
This is four equal sections.
This is divided into six equal sections.
So it's equal sections but not fourths.
Six equal sections.
So this right here is divided into sixths.
So our two rectangles that
are divided into fourths,
are this one and that one.
Four equal sections.